yeah welcome to this video a little
different video then than usual and
actually I had intended to do this with
the webcam but it died on me simply
because there's not so much in chess
content it's more about addressing some
subject of the future of this this
channel um of course I'm continuing this
channel don't don't be afraid if you
like it there will be will be new
content coming but there are some things
that needs to be m2 said to be said I'm
currently working on lots of projects
away from from the channel and these
some eat up lots of time the main time
burner is a new project that I recently
started and this is actually a an on
internet based project it's a very
classical project i'm writing a book an
opening book and it's really a ton of
work to do especially considering that
it is the first book that I'm writing
you need to learn some entirely new
things I can give you a brief idea about
the contents of this book it doesn't
have a title yet it will be a black
repertoire against Wandy form so 1 d4
and it will be based on those opening
moves I won't address any sidelines at
this stage like the Trump on let's say
color or something like that the focus
of the book sc4 e6 and now everything
that white can do so it has got the NIMS
oh and in the NIMS oh i will analyze a
couple of lines that are not so in the
spotlight at the moment and i hope to UM
yet to revive some forgotten and
unknown lines it's quite some work to do
but interesting interesting proposition
the main point is that black is trying
to set up a dark squared center in this
book so just to put something on the
board this is not an actual line but
this is the kind of stuff that blank is
aiming for I'm just just to show what
what I'm getting at so the bishop is
outside of the pawn chain and like Scott
the pawns on dark square so maybe we in
this position you should actually take
and then play this so to have a very
healthy structure with pawns on dark
squares at the light squared Bishop
white often is can also be pawns so I'm
the news of repertoire will be much
about this kind of structure on
structure that looks like this roughly
some of a closed position type with
maneuvering and strategical ideas yeah
this is the the names apart and of
course the names are also needs a
companion because lots of people play
Knight f3 and not Knight c3 and he I'm
going to propose the bogo Indian defense
which really doesn't have has received
lots of opening book coverage and in
recent years it never has been so
popular as the Queen's Indian for
example or other openings but i think
it's it's quite interesting and recently
there have been some some key
improvements for black i'm not quite
sure about the specific lines that i'm
going to choose because there's quite a
number of interesting ones to them to
select from especially after Bishop d2
there is some sea 505 and also queenie 7
which are all very much playable
and I'm not one hundred percent sure
what what I'm going from on this move
Black has a multitude of possibilities
like b6 on castles and I'm currently
working on on all those possibilities
and putting this book together it is
scheduled to be completed in a couple of
months so I'm thinking that it might be
released them to them round the end of
the year or maybe in India in autumn
like september-october everything's
going well but it's a huge time burner
so um I have problems to produce some
this somewhat more sophisticated content
for the channel like those modern
classic games or a big opening theory em
subjects as they simply eat so much time
I need to concentrate on something and
this at the moment is this book as it is
a new project and need some needs
attention and another thing that I'm
also working on at the moment which is
not eating so much time but it's also
something that that some on at the
moment is my video work for icc for the
internet chess club and this is in
german language they needed a german
language commentator and asked me enter
now i'm at the moment producing a
regular series every 14 days by weekly
show on on openings for black which
won't feature my my book my book
repertoire that currently it's about the
caro-kann as black and also i'm doing a
game of the day type of coverage and
german i did the zurich chest challenge
those six rounds and i will also do the
candidates turnabout a german language
and in fact doing those videos in German
was very enjoyable returning to my
native language so i'll also can i also
consider to do some German videos on for
YouTube but I won't do this
and under the chassis explain label if
um if I decide to do I'm German videos
once in a while then I'll probably set
up a new channel and transfer the German
videos to that channel to have an
English Channel and a German channel but
this is very much in the future I don't
don't think I would do that in the next
couple of weeks or something first of
all I need to get this book on completed
and then think about other things um
yeah this is why at the moment um
there's mostly Blitz videos on them
another reason for me doing so many
Blitz videos is that I'm this yam trying
to qualify on for the German blitz
champion ships it's not easy to do um
because some I live and known them the
part of Germany north rhine-westphalia
which is by far the strongest area in
Germany in terms of chess so to qualify
them in some other area would have been
actually really easy and north
rhine-westphalia head stuff so I'm need
to qualify through various stages and I
never tried I never managed to to play
any of those qualification tunnels but
this year they are scheduled nicely so I
can play and then want to get into a
little bit of blitz shape for those
tournaments this is also why i am doing
so many Blitz videos at the moment and
those can be done without much
preparation you need to you need to
recognize that if I producer let's say a
30 or 40 minute video for modern
classics there there's like two hours
preparation work in them I really do
lots of preparing and look what analyze
all those lines sometimes those are all
the games only have from comments from
back when they were plate and twenty
year old commentary is frankly useless
even if it was done by by the all-time
greats they simply
not compared to UM gamp some average I
am like me and and the big engine with
3,000 something you know our analysis
results are simply better it's just like
that I had some some really rough
experiences with those modern classic
videos why i tried to use the old
analysis and the first three lines that
i checked with the computer were all
wrong I mean completely wrong like the
evaluation was white is winning and
actually he was losing and this
basically means you need to prepare all
this and then also I'm take into account
that I check absolutely every move I put
on the board in those kind of videos
before and I will never do some yeah
offhand suggestion that it's not working
really it doesn't happen if you watch
other videos on YouTube it happens all
the time I mean they're full of arrows
because they are not prepared so um this
is the reason why I cannot so easily do
one of those those videos if I have
other projects going on so this is some
ten minute video already so just I hope
to transfer some current information
about the state of the channel and feel
free to leave comments and suggestions
here I'm looking forward to your to your
IDs and and feedback on all this thanks